over a century has passed since the
Morris Motor Company was founded in 1913
since William Morris decided to change
over production from bicycles to cars he
opened his first motor works in Cowley
Oxfordshire and began turning out the
Morris Oxford bullnose a few originals
have survived one is owned by Hammond
Joseph moyson
[Music]
this was one of the last in the bullnose
series built in 1926 it was followed by
the flat nose series which had a
conventional flat radiator that made the
car look like almost any other from the
period to look like oh it was the
canisters shape of the radiator that
earned it the nickname bull nose just
like the exterior the interior possesses
a distinguished British sense of
elegance the cream-colored seat and
wooden dashboard seemed to recall a
vintage sailboat the speedometer is
marked in miles per hour
ahman yosef has added the km/h around
the outside edge when counting the
rumble seat four people can fit into the
open two-seater torpedo Hammond Joseph
had his own very aesthetic reasons for
choosing this particular car he knew
just what he was looking for to him it's
a thing of beauty for one because of the
colors the black and maroon sent against
the nickel trim he's always been
fascinated by cars but he wanted to own
one that you don't see on every corner
but was still in an affordable range he
describes himself as the average Joe
consumer so he was lucky to be able to
acquire the car and to drive it and the
Cowley presented the opportunity because
the price wasn't out of reach
he's been intensely interested in
vintage cars for some years now
he caught the bug all of a sudden in
particular for the really old cars the
pre-war cars as the English say schnell
finished infancy at 101 done hospital is
a country identified so he has a four
kliks parts or pre-war cars for the in
another
but pre-war cars aren't always easy to
start you have to put some muscle into
cranking the engine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
over a hundred years ago William Morris
was aiming to become a well-known maker
of high quality automobiles but he was
neither a trained engineer nor an
enthusiastic racecar driver his first
car was based simply on his own
practical experience by 1912 he was
ready to put his plans into practice and
found an investor at the time the
automobile industry and market were
growing by leaps and bounds and
competition was fierce 64 car makers
started up between 1911 and 1914 but
only 46 were still operating in the
years after among them was William
Morris Hammond Joseph thoroughly enjoys
gallivanting about in his Cowley even if
it doesn't offer much in the way of
luxury
[Music]
you points out that it takes a bit more
skill to drive than today's cars the
gears for example aren't synchronized
and there's no power steering or power
brakes nor any of the other modern
electronic helpers the gas pedal is in
the middle that takes some getting used
to
and as an English car it's got its
steering wheel on the right but as
Hammond Yosef has no desire to pass
anyone on the road that was no problem
once he gotten used to it with an engine
performance of just 18 kilowatts and top
speed of 90 km/h passing modern cars
might be rather difficult but Hammond
Yosef doesn't care all he uses the car
for is a bit of joyriding or a Sunday
Drive
[Music]
to him the experience is indescribably
beautiful especially just coasting along
nobody's annoyed when he pokes along at
50 or 60 km/h he's just out to enjoy the
wind and nature and the sunshine in
terms of driving at least he can't
imagine anything better it's only a few
more years till his Cali can celebrate
its hundredth birthday
Hammond Yosef is already looking forward
to the party
you